this week it was officially recorded by
johns hopkins university that over one
million people worldwide have now
died from covet 19. since the first
recorded death in wuhan china
in mid-january covet 19 has taken an
average of more than 3 800 lives per day
the united states continues to lead the
world's death toll
at just over 200 000 brazil is second
with just over 140 000 deaths and india
is third
with just over 95 000 deaths it's also
the most rapidly growing geographical
area for new infections
officially china has recorded just under
5 000 deaths due to covet 19
however some international observers
have disputed the accuracy of that data
and believe the actual death count could
be higher few major countries
have been able to completely subdue
their covet 19 outbreaks
but some like new zealand and south
korea have managed to keep their death
counts
low others like spain and the united
kingdom have seen cases rise again after
lockdown measures were eased
most health officials believe a vaccine
should be ready for public consumption
by next year
however the world health organization
warns that the global death toll
could reach 2 million by the time a
vaccine is widely available
you